Kirra Road in who says hey David in the
wake of the Sam cedar intellectual
property theft scandal are you open to
having your set totally redesigned by
the audience so the answer is yes sure
with some caveats which I'll get to in a
second if you've not been following the
Sam cedar intellectual property theft
controversy the paneling that I have
behind me surrounding the TV is a
hundred and thirty nine dollar panel
from Ikea which Sam uses on his set and
before I bought it I said to Sam I want
to integrate that as an element to my
set where'd you get it and Sam told me
and now there has been this whole kind
of controversy put together which we're
all I guess pretending is really real
and really really serious and might come
to lawsuits and that type of stuff and
people by the way are now pointing to
the fact that it appears Sam stole his
set maybe from Rachel Maddow maybe from
the program Smallville or who knows from
where I don't even care at this point
but to answer the question I'm totally
open to having the set redesigned I
would love to have the audience's help I
say that knowing that any time I ask the
audience for help I get about one or two
percent brilliant ideas I'd never have
thought of myself and 98 to 99 percent
things that make no sense that I have to
wade through with that in mind I'm
always open to ideas from the audience
we've had this set now for about five
months and usually there's some element
that's changed like every eight to ten
months either a camera shot lighting a
background element the framing of
something so I'm ready to start setting
up the next series of tweaks and I
welcome ideas from the audience and I
know that I'm opening up Pandora's box
when I do that